Josh Norman back here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you Josh hey man how you
doing there was a fifth quarter going on
I wish it was I really wish it was [ __ ]
oh I wasn't even tired after that I felt
like you know how II didn't do much but
it was fun it was a fun collective team
win and I think it was uh there wasn't
much needed for everyone to see
now a lot of work do you did you feel
disrespected don't in that game for real
like literally disrespected know
anything about to be quite honest with
you it was something that um and it
wasn't even crowd sure it was it was
cool that I said that because I felt one
of the teammates um you know they wanted
this it's changed there's a high the
case may be so he said he felt like he
wanted to frame his and that was a
conversation that they had and I was
told about it so I was like oh really so
that's really what he was gonna do I was
like did he know he's playing he did you
check the schedule did he did he see
like that never happened in my entire
existence is playing a football not even
in the National Football League mad at
college or high school I know whenever
it came within a sniff of that so what
he thought was gonna happen in that was
my whole tape so you know I took that
out of my field keeping it in my back of
my mind the whole time you know and I
wasn't gonna say anything but ink come
Crabtree doing all the extra stuff so I
had put on notice and then that was the
whole conversation that we was having in
the game so after the fact you know
Montague went over and weighed into his
ribs I guess he went out with chest
pains I guess that's what happens when
you know you run off with as you do but
what about the idea Josh that you are
you've already reached the level of play
and respect in this league that you
don't have to say stuff like that and
the
why I'm bringing this up is did you see
what Dion and LT said about your
comments on NFL Network gameday prime on
Sunday you know and you know that's why
they see where they see them that's what
I see when it's didn't you know kind of
reporting those things cuz they're they
not a player anymore you know they don't
they don't have that you know how would
I say in them to do that they don't play
the game anymore so what they do they
wake up every morning they may go to a
workout or something on their own time
if they feel free to do it and then they
broadcast about people all day they're
not out here in the Sun and I how it
working and I hear bat Tillman trying to
be the best big candy they just report
they just see what they see and they
talk about it it they got a bust in a
certain room where I'm sure you know
they do got a bus nobody's taking that
away from them and a lot is like
disrespecting that you know I definitely
get my hat's off to them and respect
that they are Hall of Famers nobody ever
gonna take that away from them and I'm
not saying they're they're not and I
respect the heck out of them for what
they have done for our league and you
know the players that came before us
which are them and I respect that about
them and I respect everything they've
done in their career that's why they are
Hall of Famers but what I don't is you
coming and saying something about
somebody who's actually playing in it
and they'd give me a whole heart
20:50 percent effort on everything they
do in the game while they're playing it
and then after the fact you're those
hereo you sound like a wrestler because
I'm still in the moment of the game
thank you like for some people you know
you get out of that and then I'm cool
but guess what I was in that moment in
time I felt there was me that he said
because shoot I worked out my tail all
week up for that all week up for that I
mean everyone they give us a doubt and
chance everything get a shot to do it we
did and we did it and when you have that
feeling of you become successful no I
like who is someone to tell me sit down
and you should be talking like this you
should be quiet in a certain sense get
out of here you haven't been putting
that work on a [ __ ] I did that we
leading up to it don't
we did those guys so Owen here that
that's something that you you have to
say just do it on your own time you know
what I'm saying but it I like I said I
don't disrespect them any kind of weight
they're Hall of Famers they do have a
name choose to do but don't come and
talk about me
and don't say nothing about me if you
don't know what kind of work we put into
it on that we lean up into that game do
you we're doing it alright I'll run tell
that at my other shop but my my Sunday
job my Thursday job on the NFL Network
that's Rajasa Norman here on the Rich
Eisen show what about this Monday you're
gonna have another National League
televised audience what are the Chiefs
present to you as a challenge Josh well
member 18 that's for first and foremost
get that out the way they are on the no
1 team in the league right now there is
no man they have more more power weapons
at their disposal Arsenal is deep they
have fire skies that can light it up at
any moment they got a quarterback that
can get it to me any moment they got a
running back who they break it open and
any given time of the game so we'll wear
that we got our work cut out for us and
you know it starts for us yesterday so
we've been on that and we understand the
opponent that we're facing and that
Arrowhead Stadium which is gonna be loud
so we just gotta be mindful of who we
face in it and try to you know come out
with victory I know it'll be hard but
there's gotta work Dino well I mean in
terms of what you can serve notice on
the country is hanging the first loss of
the season on the Chiefs and they're
building that would certainly suffice
Josh I mean if you thought you made a
statement with the Raiders that would
that would be the next one what do you
think well you know we we just trying to
do this football team I think just
trying to find out identity I think it's
coming to the part where you know we can
do some really good stuff a lot of
people they didn't care to put us on
anybody list only thing that we care is
over 53 men that locker room along with
the you know the players on practice
squad and the coaches that's it I
thought it really mattered so when we
get to that point
you know finding out where we want to be
as a team we don't want her people just
jumping on our Pam we're gonna be like
oh yeah well no it's gonna be a lot of
people saying well I made a mistake
I gotta suffer up to this you know a lot
of people gonna be in Croke keep our
heads down and keep pushing and driving
and you know good things come to those
who can put work into it how good is
this kid Chris Thompson Josh got me
all-around special guy not only only
football field officers as well tell me
about that
tell me about that because I've seen the
on-field stuff and he is electric what
about what do you mean by off the field
no guy like God all around like I've
never seen Chris you know have any
trouble with him I've never seen him you
know misdemeanour be late to anything
he's always on time always showing up
he's always at first a lot Connor and
you know he does his work he does it
quietly
but it's respectable everything he does
I watched him over a year or two now and
it's just been amazing to see how his
transformation he's been doing it for a
while but man I can't do enough good
things about a minute when you see him
on the field he's just as electric as he
is on the field on Sunday practice so
there's no shock to me that he's doing
all right
Josh are you guys talking about the the
next game pre and anthem about what
you're gonna do yet or is there is there
a conversation about that about how to
how do how to do things before the game
came up be quite honest with you I mean
it was really focusing on her but she
said there's a moment in time I think
maybe later on the week we'll have
something if that conversation come up
but right now I'm in focus on cheese and
I know that everybody you know
individually have some thoughts still on
you know how to make a situation that's
horrible better but right now like I
said we just focused on cheese and
playing them at Arrowhead Stadium on
Monday night I think everything else
good teacher so as always
talking to you Josh I'll tell Dion and
lt you said hello but I think he did
that already yeah
guilty he's my gosh is what it is I
respect these positions like I said yeah
man I'm beat me I can't be nobody else
and we're liking tonight for the
popularity contest I'm here to screw
your guys in the face take care of
yourself Josh good luck Monday night
I'll be watching the man at Jay
underscore and o24 the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy